we begin tonight with our continuing
coverage of the utter devastation caused
by Hurricane Harvey some areas in Texas
received over 50 inches of rain creating
what one scientist is calling a once in
every thousand years flooding event Vice
President Mike Pence visited with storm
survivors in Texas today and president
Trump is donating 1 million dollars of
his own money to storm victims the
latest on Harvey and it's aftermath
let's go to Steve Harrigan in Silsby
Texas
Steve Jesse no rain here right now but
east of Houston the flood waters keep
rising and that's really caught a lot of
people here by surprise throughout the
day we saw a number of water rescues
some people going out and flat boats to
pick up neighbors others to pick up
their pets and in the case we're about
to show you both we didn't really have
much floating until just this morning
started coming fast a fence line it
started rushing toward it so we got
three acres out there and I want to say
probably 4/5 of instant underwater why'd
you decide to come shut off the power we
didn't have no water or foods we said
gherkin the rescuer in that case
actually came from Arkansas he told us
that he had the resources in the time
and wanted to help he's been saving
people for two days Jesse back to you
Steve thank you
the press is covering president Trump's
every move related to hurricane Harvey
and no matter what the president does it
seems the mainstream media says it's not
enough I don't think that he understands
the human scale of misery I don't think
that he can connect with the sort of
compassion that you normally have when
you see a disaster like this and it was
very striking that he didn't mention the
number of people who have died or even
you know sort of try to empathize with
the fact that people are genuinely
suffering the fact that he saw no damage
firsthand did not stop him from claiming
on Twitter he witnessed quote firsthand
the horror and devastation caused by
Hurricane Harvey and today at the White
House press briefing the press corps
seemed more concerned about illegal
parents and anybody else affected by
Harvey there are five hundred and
seventy five thousand undocumented
immigrants in Houston one of the largest
populations in this country does this
White House believe they should be
eligible for long term federal recovery
assistance I'm just a little bit
confused but your answer justice Elia I
go back to that on undocumented
immigrants getting long-term funding is
that a yes or a No is the administration
supporting you are an undocumented
immigrant and you did have a home and
how do I just drawing the blood you are
a center what happened what happens Greg
all those undocumented immigrants
they're probably more deserving
according to the press corps what relief
than actual residents of Texas I would
get being concerned and I being
concerned about everyone from the
undocumented to the documented but it
seems to when you listen to the press
it's as if only undocumented or illegal
immigrants are involved in this disaster
which makes me think they really don't
care that this is a political point that
they're trying to make I would never say
the media is trying to do this by the
way it was you know both sides do this
the side out of power always if goes
after the side in power during Hurricane
sandy there was a lot of criticism about
Obama hugging Chris Christie do you
remember that but mainly but the
interesting thing I think this is a
different time I don't think Trump is as
president Trump is as big a factor in
this because it seems like Texas
represents such a positive unifying
force that people can't really turn this
into a bad thing
it's like Texas Texas's new motto should
be we got this yeah because they I mean
it's like Trump is not the unity speaks
for itself so when you start talking
about troubled Trump not being warm and
fuzzy like a like a bunny slipper people
like we don't need it we got this we're
fine we don't need a cozy fuzzy banana
you know or a bunny slipper bunny
slipper as a leader as a leader we can
do it ourselves and you see it every day
so I think it's really hard for the
media to go after him at this point
because the visuals convey convey the
message they convey the message that he
wants to convey which
is making America great again which is
the positive nature of people coming
together he's just kind of in the
background so they can't really this
stuff is baby games that's right in the
media thinks Texas wants tears yeah and
they want volunteers they want food they
want shelter that's not what Texas needs
right now Kimberly but for some reason
the press wants the photo off of the
president crying and hugging like a Bill
Clinton we're at Obama well if he did
that they would say that oh this is just
totally put upon the world with artifice
this is someone trying to save this
political presidency they would not have
any time wasted hitting him and
attacking him and saying that it was
crocodile tears what I think here is to
be celebrated is the fact that people
have come together an incredible
unparalleled humanitarian effort to be
able to help one another to be able to
provide that the funding provide the
food the resources the rescue efforts to
bring people together this to me is a
really shining example of the best of
American cooperative efforts trying to
help one another of our unity about what
unites us rather than what divides us so
I think this has been in a way a time of
healing through tremendous tragedy where
people have said you know what we really
actually have so much more in common
than what the media was into the
mainstream media the press will tell us
that divides us and that I think is
really important it is important but the
press seems focused on the empathy
factor one and they're saying I don't
know how they get this information that
they believe that the president doesn't
care and he lacks empathy towards the
actual victims back up to the election I
think Hillary Clinton was the robot that
couldn't connect and couldn't show
empathy President Trump won in November
because you get empathize with that
forgotten man the victims of unfair
trade deals the victims of open borders
and and bad deals that's what got him
elected I'm not sure but okay I mean I
think that's an element I mean people
say lots of things about what got him
elected I don't know for sure but I tell
you when it comes to this issue I think
that you know Kimberly to me was right
on target no matter what he did if he
had gone down in Texas if he'd actually
gone
under the frontlines people say well you
know what he's going through the motions
to try to create an image that will
appeal to Americans well he didn't do it
so when the president says but you
didn't do it and guess what we have a
Fox News poll out today that says only
26% of Americans think of him as a
compassionate person I think it plays in
to a negative image about his weaknesses
and so the press then says well look I
mean this guy doesn't seem very
compassionate and you guys say oh that's
the mainstream press or on the
immigrants issue who has made
immigration the centerpiece of his
campaign maybe that's the reason he got
elected because he was hard on illegal
immigrants immigrants in general and and
now when people say well what about you
know are they stopping immigrants that
the checkpoints are they going to do
some kind of sleep at the shelter's to
find illegal immigrants are illegal
immigrants eligible for benefits all
these questions bubble up because he has
demonstrated such an antipathy towards
him I don't nobody high like nobody
looks for a surgeon based on empathy
they look for skillsets it's like that
is the worst thing maybe a psychologist
or a priest if you want empathy go
that's fine but the thing is you're
asking asking Trump for empathy you
don't get it that's not why I was
elected you don't even have to like
Trump to think you're a good president
right but I agree with you but I'm
telling he's a politician and we have
seen I think I think it was a highlight
of President Bush's time when he stood
there and says I hear you in the
wreckage after 9/11 yeah but I think
they're trying to fit Trump into the
political mold and they're upset the
media is because Trump's not playing by
the media playbook he's not going down
there and hugging and crying like every
other politician does so then the media
will write a story that says because
he's not acting hi quote acting like a
politician he's not a president you're
jello mold that's why right I kind of
feel like this is a question of
leadership style if we break it down
what we're really talking about here
right I think it's fair to compare and
contrast different presidents in the
wake of national disasters I think it's
fair to evaluate all of them it's fair
to say okay President Trump has not
on this sort of consoler in chief
attitude he has not maybe been so overly
emotive he's not been hugging people but
I think that to extrapolate from that
the idea that he is somehow not
empathetic is not fair and I think
that's lazy analysis I also think it's
weird sort of like pop psychology right
people are mind-reading on to the press
it's my dream I think that if we're
going to talk about his leadership style
in the wake of this storm I think it has
really been him adopting his chief
executive officer mode right put that
hat on he's established a cheer clear
chain of command VP pence is out on the
ground today clearly acting is the CEO
oh you know if America is this
corporation I think this is how he
approaches it it's like we've got this
strategic problem how am I going to fix
things who's gonna handle what who am i
delegating to that's the style we've
seen from President Trump so it's fair
to talk about what we think about that
but I think to condemn him for choosing
one style over another is not there and
shoo gate continues everybody the
Washington Post I believe Kimberly
doubled down on attacking milania's high
heels saying totally fair game to go
after the first lady's choice of
footwear what do you think about that I
don't know but you had tennis shoes on
or sneakers or kicks whatever you guys
want to call them these days yeah and
they didn't guess they didn't have a
problem with that I think this is
childish and I think it's immature
why don't they cover the real stories
that are out there about the human
suffering and the people's will to live
and to help and to give back and to try
to you know unite people they don't want
to do that because that's not a fun
story they'd rather poke fun at somebody
who's actually been a fantastic first
lady and represented us well in an
elegant way why is it always only the
women yeah that annoys me I think it is
sexist this is okay this is what
Washington Post did which is so
hilarious they wanted to do this story
but they wanted to protect themselves
from the criticism of being sexist so
the headline is it's not sexist to go
after Melania because the shoes imply
that she wasn't thinking about others I
believe that the Washington Post was
sexist in choosing a woman to do this
story
Kaela Epstein because that provided them
with the camouflage trash the first lady
it's about trashing the first lady if
you look at the Twitter feeds of kale
Epstein not about of Trump fan by any
means but they used her they used her
sex to cover this so she's just a pond
and in the Washington Post a way to
avoid looking sexist but I think that
Caleb seems she's on her way to getting
a Pulitzer if they have a category for
shoes well let me just think what's
Berta Boston Post worst of all let me
just say I think it was Robin given who
is the post fashion writer who first
wrote about this and so maybe you could
say oh well is the fashion people where
they don't win six what decision they
thought they assumed that men can't
write about you all know each other only
women can do it well let the chicks
write about the shoes that's sexist
that's written for I've run for needs of
women's magazines I've run for dozens I
let me do this but let me just say I saw
in the New York Times today that their
top story the story that was most read
in the New York Times yesterday was
guess what the shoes the shoes yeah so I
think there's widespread interest in
this now why an during why o pandering I
don't know right in the gutter with a
key I think there are a lot of people
who see this as evidence that this is
the high-class the super-rich the
billionaire it's an out-of-touch class
warfare and what okay class warfare but
nonetheless what it suggests is she's
out of touch and that you know kids
don't like it hey Kimberly I hate to
tell you this but Kimberly said they
didn't get to the sneakers they did get
to the sneakers they said the sneakers
were glistening okay she was the worst
person for wearing the sneakers I mean
how many articles talked about River
letters and it was reveal yeah I mean
where where was the way to caring about
what they've been talking wearing a hat
and a jacket that you can buy all right
fine but ya know criticism that he
picked the we also gave a million
dollars okay Joey my point guy certainly
Washington Post goes out of its way to
find women to attack the women so they
don't look sexist but it's actually
sexist to choose the women to be the
attackers happens all that it's kind of
sad weird and Greg would gladly write
about women's shoes if you judge
give them the chance I can write a mean
piece on shoes